the Joe Rogan experience Oh No
so the software algorithm and Facebook
is not as affected on't really give a
[ __ ] they don't care yeah they're too
busy selling your information so [ __ ]
Russia
totally Jamie was watching the video of
Zuckerberg how did it go he should know
the answer he dad had to go again today
yeah and I was watching right before you
got here in this I don't know where she
was from but she was saying like you're
the CEO of this company and you should
know some of these answers and she was
like listing all the [ __ ] he didn't know
yeah yeah I was like this is ridiculous
night afterwards now they've shown which
I guess it's a part of now public
information his notes
oh no that he had like as references
that he was looking at I've only seen
one picture of it mm-hmm just very weird
stuff that like seems blatantly obvious
that he should know or should say that's
different from what we thought maybe we
think we should yeah I think they should
be able to tell us I get the impression
that this company grew so fast that they
don't even know what the [ __ ] is going
on in there well that was the other
thing he was talking about their
influence on possibly he was talking
about his influence on all these
different upcoming elections that were
coming up and about how they wanted to
make sure that there was no BOTS that
were influencing these elections and I
stopped and thought about it I'm like oh
my god in that moment of him saying that
I realized like what pressure he must be
under what pressure that company is
under there they went from being a thing
where people could share pictures like
of hey this is us on our summer vacation
like hey you know [ __ ] we're gonna go
to the pub on Friday
that's what Facebook kind of was right
people would talk about certain things
in the news they would have opinions you
put up something a bunch of people
comment on it that's what it was now
with this last election and with him
testifying in front of Congress what I'm
seeing is Facebook being like one of the
most important sources of influence in
the world today and it's not really
being completely managed oh I feel like
the Russians the Russians yeah maybe
there's a little bit like Google needs
to be looked into what's going on Mike
so we'll go also probably like they have
a data I think someone was just looking
into the
you know people downloaded their
Facebook profile and they're like my
files one gigabyte how much data is in
here right people found out a way to
download theirs and find their
information what what does Facebook know
about me well apparently there's also
one that Google has on everyone and it's
much larger I'm not shocked you know I
wouldn't be I wouldn't be nervous if it
wasn't for that I that d'amore memo
thing really changed my mind
about a lot of things not because you
know it's a subject that's near and dear
to my heart but because I the way they
were handling it was not there were we
weren't being honest they were they
weren't being honest about the science
they weren't being honest about the
reaction they were even the way they
were describing it we're talking about
the James do more Google memo oh I don't
know uh was it the sexism thing who's
that well as the the witty was talking
about women in tech explain why women
would prefer to not like why some women
are not influenced by it the way Google
handled it was very may be very nervous
because they weren't being honest about
the information they weren't being
honest about the results they weren't be
honest about what was in his they were
saying he was reinforcing harmful gender
stereotypes that's not what he was doing
he what he was talking about the science
of the difference in the psychology
between men and women and why women
would gravitate towards different
careers maybe that's why more women
aren't in tech
maybe there's ways to get women intact
well you've taken that angle before
right with women and fighting and women
in sports right yeah there's some women
that are not gonna want to be into those
things or some women that are going to
be men it's less likely that a woman's
gonna be into fighting than a man I
don't think that's extraordinary to say
but a lot of women are into it it
doesn't mean that it's impossible but
it's just we're looking at human beings
like if you're an outlier and you're a
woman who really loves to fight there's
nothing wrong with that I'm not saying
is anything wrong with that but I'm
saying it's much more rare than a woman
who wants to you know do become a nurse
or do something that's traditionally a
female caregiver sort of a position
which is really common and Isis did the
letter memo indicate like this that
science says women were less predisposed
to becoming pro
hammers or something like that no no
it's it just was talking about gender
like choices and choices people make and
why they make them based on personality
traits and how why things are more
common certain things are more common in
males certain things are more common to
women and that this would indicate why
there were less women that were involved
in tech and it wasn't some systemic sort
of discrimination campaign right on by
men you know but my point was we were
talking about them having all the
information that you have like Google
and yes book how much information they
had on you it would make me less nervous
if I didn't know about that how they
handled that Google memo thing cuz I'm
like well you guys are being honest
about what this is and what the guy
wrote you're paying the guy out to be a
villain
and you think if you fire him and drown
this that this story goes out and then
you guys get to look like social justice
warriors yeah and then you don't take
the heat from the what you know is an
objective analysis of this issue well I
don't I'm not sure Mark Zuckerberg has a
lot of incentive to be totally honest in
this case either he's totally honest and
he's malicious or he's totally honest
and he's almost comically ignorant about
certain things yeah he's I think he's
almost got to say he doesn't know but
the problem is they can prove he knows
he should know yes well here's the thing
he should know
now him saying he doesn't know what if
they can pull up an email yeah well I
mean what if they have access to all of
his emails and it shows that he knows
that they did I was talking to yesterday
about it and we were like worried about
the Facebook recording thing is anybody
gonna bring that up and and it was
brought up and he said that they don't
record audio Facebook doesn't write you
were talking about it with Google
weren't you we talking about it with
Google that if you talked if you were
talking in a room about a certain
subject I felt that happen right it's
the Apple home pod you think you've had
you've been talking about something in a
room and then had popup ads pop up right
no I have it no no no no I believe it
though
have you had it it happened to me before
not I don't know how I couldn't tell you
what where the signals went but I've
definitely had strain it could be a
coincidence but I've had strange ads pop
up that are I read that that I don't
know if it's accurate though what I was
reading that there have people
I've tried to prove and it could be
people on Facebook side just to give him
propaganda that that's almost nearly
impossible to do right now just the rest
of the technology would take to record
your audio have it scanned by something
and then deliver and add to you based
off of that in amount of time yeah it's
possible I could have looked at
something similar at a recent time or it
would just was just far enough away for
me to not make an exact connection I
don't think would represent though is
that you recognize that that is
potentially in the future
[Applause]